DISBHNCH ♪ ♪
>> Laura: THE HOUSE IS NOW JUST
5 GOP VOTES AWAY FROM BRINGING
SEVERAL DACA BILLS TO THE HOUSE
FLOOR VIA A DISCHARGE POSITION.
IT'S A TACTIC TO GET AROUND THE
GOP LEADERSHIP THAT WE TOLD YOU
ABOUT LAST NIGHT.
SO-CALLED MODERATE REPUBLICANS
AND DEMOCRATS ARE WORKING
TOGETHER TO ADVANCE A BILL THAT
WOULD GIVE AMNESTY TO DREAMERS.
THAT'S THE GOAL.
SPEAKER PAUL RYAN CALLS THE
EFFORT POINTLESS BECAUSE THE
PRESIDENT WOULD VETO IT.
THE INSIDE STORY FROM THE HOUSE
MAJORITY WHIP.
CONGRESSMAN THIS IS UPSETTING TO
A LOT OF US WHO HAVE SEEN HOW
THIS MOTIVE ENDS.
-- MOVIES ENDS.
IT WAS SO BAD THAT EVEN MARCO
RUBIO STEPPED BACK FROM IT.
WHAT IS HAPPENING?
>> WELL, LAURA, IT'S GOOD TO BE
BACK WITH YOU.
I DON'T WANT TO SEE THIS BECAUSE
I WANT TO SOLVE THE PROBLEM.
I AM A CO-SPONSOR THAT ADDRESSES
ALL OF THE ISSUES.
SECURE THE BORDER AND CHAIN
MIGRATION AND ADDRESS DACA WHICH
WAS A PROBLEM THAT BARACK OBAMA
CREATED:
COME TO THIS COUNTRY AND BRING
YOUR KIDS.
IT'S ILLEGAL.
WE WILL JUST LOOK THE OTHER WAY
AND LET SOMEBODY ELSE FIX IT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WANTS TO SOLVE
THIS PROBLEM.
WE ARE WORKING WITH PRESIDENT
TRUMP TO GET A SOLUTION.
BLANKET AMNESTY WITH NO BORDER
PROTECT AND NO WALL IS NOT THE
ANSWER.
>> Laura: WHAT HAPPENED BEHIND
CLOSED DOORS?
YOU HAD A BIG MEETING AND IT GOT
HEATH.
-- HEATED.
>> IMIGATION IS ALWAYS A
COMPLICATED ISSUE.
>> Laura: THE PRESIDENT RAN ON
LAW AND ORDER AT THE BORDER AND
CONGRESS PASSES A BILL THAT
DOESN'T FUND THE WALL.
THE PRESIDENT WAS LED TO BELIEVE
IT DID.
>> 110 MILES OF THE WALL, BUT WE
WANT A LONG-TERM SOLUTION.
THE FULL FUNDING FOR THE WALL.
THE OTHER ISSUES IMPORTANT.
INTERIOR INFORCEMENT.
THIS CATCH AND RELEASE AND OTHER
PROGRAMS, YOU COULD HAVE A FELON
COME OUT OF PRISON AND THEY
CAN'T BE DEPORTED.
WE NEED TO CLOSE THOSE LOOPHOLES
AND END THOSE PROBLEMS.
FRIENDS OF MINE WORKED HARD TO
GET BACK TO THE RULE OF LAW AND
SECURE OUR BORDER.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WANTS TO SOLVE
THE PROBLEM.
>> Laura: WHAT NANCY PELOSI SAID
TODAY.
>> CLEAN UP ALL OF THEIR BILLS.
CLEAN UP THE HILL.
WE BELIEVE THIS BIPARTISAN BILL
THAT THE MEMBERS PUT TOGETHER
THAT SHARE THE VALUE OF
PROTECTING THE DREAMERS IS THE
BILL THAT WOULD WIN.
WE HAVE AN ANSWER.
THERE IS A TASK.
LET'S GET IT DONE.
IF NOT, WHY NOT?
>> Laura: EVERYONE WATCHING
SHOULD KNOW THAT THE 20
REPUBLICANS PUSHING THIS
DISCHARGE PETITION ARE WITH THE
PERSON ON THE SCREEN, NANCY
PELOSI.
THAT'S SHOCKING!
40% OF AMERICANS SAY THE COUNTRY
IS GOING IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
IT WAS 30% A YEAR AGO.
>> AND THAT NUMBER IS GROWING.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS GETTING THE
ECONOMY MOVING AGAIN.
WORKING WITH US ON SO MANY
ISSUES THAT ARE MEANINGFUL.
NANCY PELOSI SAID IF SHE WAS
SPEAKER AGAIN SHE WOULD RAISE
YOUR TAXES AND UNDO THE GREAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP TAX CUTS.
WHEN NANCY PELOSI WAS THE
SPEAKER, SHE NEVER TRIED TO FIX
THIS PROBLEM.
IT WASN'T UNTIL SHE LOST THE
MAJORITY, THAT SHE WANTED TO DO
SOMETHING.
THEY WANT IT AS A POLITICAL
ISSUE.
WE WANT TO SOLVE THE PROBLEM BUT
IN A WAY THAT RESTORES RULE OF
LAW.
>> Laura: YOU AND MCCARTHY HAVE
HELD A TOUGH STANCE AND
REFLECTING THE WILL OF THE
PEOPLE AND THE PRESIDENT'S
AGENDA WHICH IS THE ONLY PATH
FORWARD FOR THE GOP AT THIS
POINT.
JEFF WAS ON MARTHA MacCALLUM --
TUCKER'S SHOW, HE SAID THIS IS
THE WAY TO DELIVER A SOLUTION TO
THE PRESIDENT.
THE PRESIDENT WANTS A SOLUTION.
THIS IS THE ANSWER.
HE SAID THERE ARE A LOT OF BILLS
THAT ARE NOT POSSIBLE BUT WE ARE
DELIVERING A COMPREHENSIVE
SOLUTION THAT WILL STOP THE
500,000 PEOPLE A YEAR CROSSING
THE BORDER.
>> JEFF IS A FRIEND, BUT WE
DISAGREE STRONGLY ON.
THIS I THINK THAT'S THE WRONG
APPROACH.
WE WANT TO WORK WITH PRESIDENT
TRUMP TO FIND A SOLUTION.
PROPOSING SOME IDEA TO BRING THE
DREAM ACT TO THE HOUSE FLOOR AND
PASS SOMETHING LIKE THE DREAM
ACT, BLANKET AMNESTY WITH NO
BORDER SECURITY, THAT'S NOT THE
RIGHT ANSWER.
BILL.
WHY PURSUE AN AGENDA --
>> Laura: WHY ARE THEY DOING IT?
>> WHY WON'T WE WORK TOGETHER?
>> Laura: ARE THEY TRYING TO
EMBARRASS THE PRESIDENT?
>> THEY COME FROM DISTRICTS
WHERE THEY WANT TO DO SOMETHING
DIFFERENT.
LET'S GET THE RIGHT SOLUTION
THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL SIGN.
>> Laura: YOU ARE TOO NICE.
I AM FROM CONNECTICUT.